hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we're going to be
talking about the new dlc heroes that
have been kind of been speculating on
the forerunner subreddit as of recent
last night a post one out by sega k for
honor subreddit member named bones 404
and he said the new dlc heroes and has a
picture of the Centurion and the ninja
as shown in the thumbnail this video now
what's kind of interesting is the way
that all of these characters look I mean
they do look like real characters if
they were to be placed in the game but
there's been a lot of questions arising
is this faker is it real why are there
two temporary pictures showing that look
like skeleton warriors why are they in
there why are these two in the same
faction but they're not like of the same
like groups for example you would think
a ninja would be more of a samurai and a
Centurion be more of a Roman or a night
in in terms of for honor now one key
example of this or one reason for this
could be as a placeholder a lot of
gaming companies use placeholders to
kinda make their time make their job a
lot easier when making certain heroes or
characters for example an old character
in or an old boss and World of Warcraft
named her sock excuse me if I have a
pronounced that wrong it carries a boss
from World of Warcraft named earth sock
they had to pay had a placeholder for
his name called rawr I'm a bear and for
this one the Centurion and the ninja
have both the placeholder as scrub mode
now clearly these are price holders they
wouldn't be there in the first they
wouldn't be there as in the game so
they're just there so that Ubisoft can
go back to a change the word scrublord
to whatever they want it to be instead
of placing it there it just makes their
time a lot easier now what is also kind
of confusing is the skeleton warriors
just like before they are they're
probably placeholders for more DLC
characters they're coming out with and
yes this is in a different language but
it doesn't really matter but I like how
the texture looks for the textures for
all these characters like how badass
there the ninjas got his little so it
looks come many sites with a rope on the
end
turians got the huge badass Roman armor
with the ads sticking out and everything
the dope look and helmet is it very well
done this could definitely be characters
for the new game I want too late I want
to know what you guys can come in the
comments if you guys think this is real
or not or would you kind of like about
these new characters I don't think
they're going to be adding a new faction
for them because that would just make
the whole faction more really weird and
it have to update everything and if you
such a pain in the ass so I don't know
if they're going to add it to like the
existing three factions oh they're going
to make their own new faction no UV soft
hasn't really explained anything yet but
I uh I hope you guys do enjoy this video
just like i said in the comments before
let me know if anything like caught your
eye if you think this is real or fake if
you have any evidence to prove that
stuff like that but I hope you guys did
enjoy like the video if you did super if
you want more for on or videos i'm
always pumping these out and i hope you
guys have a great day and that's peace
out